bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 29 février le débat à l'assemblée
nationale après le voyage de lionel
jospin en israël et en cisjordanie et en
cisjordanie
un ton en dessous de la polémique
entretenue depuis 48 heures douze ans de
réclusion c'est le réquisitoire à
mi-chemin contre l'abbé morel accusé de
viol plaidoiries de la défense en ce
moment même à rodez dans un peu plus de
24 heures au texas le condamné à mort
audel barnes sera exécutée malgré toutes
les demandes de clémence il est doute
très fort sur sa culpabilité
petit à petit tout peut s'acheter et se
vendre via internet de l'alimentation
jusqu'aux automobile cette pratique
progresse si les mains avec le goût des
autres réalisé par agnès jaoui un film
réjouissant contre tous les préjugés
avec notamment jean pierre bacri qui est
ce soir notre invité on attendait lionel
jospin on attendait ses réponses aux
questions suscitées par les incidents de
son voyage en cisjordanie et surtout ses
explications sur une possible politique
différente de la france au proche orient
après l'utilisation du mot terroriste
par le premier ministre pour qualifier
le hezbollah au liban les échanges ont
été direct très applaudie dans chaque
camp si bien lorsque monsieur jospin
s'est exprimé que lorsque hervé de
charette pour l'udf et alain juppé pour
le rpr l'ont questionné mais l'ensemble
de ces interventions est resté
relativement diplomatique compte rendu
de cet après midi au palais bourbon
enlevés jean baptiste preda lisfranc
soit granier michel levasseur la
décontraction affichée mais la tension
sensible dans l'assemblée la grande
explication ne s'est pas fait attendre
une première question venue des bons
communiste et lionel jospin revient sur
ses propos tenus en israël et sur le
proche orient
en ce qui concerne le liban et au delà
d'un mot controversé
j'ai entendu dénoncer l'enchaînement
délibéré de la violence voulue comme un
obstacle aux phrases il perspectives de
paix d'aujourd'hui après la gauche c'est
la droite qui questionne re demande des
explications
ces modes
l'image brouillée de la france après les
graves incidents de l'université de bir
zeit et lionel jospin reprend la parole
je peux vous dire que la france n'a pas
été humilié non seulement parce que je
me suis comporté de façon digne face à
la violence mais ensuite parce que
supposer que la france soit humiliée et
supposer qu avait raison ce qui habille
wright montrent effectivement caillassé
troisième temps troisième question alain
juppé le ton est plus direct lionel
jospin est accusé d'avoir changé le
discours de la france au proche orient
je me demande si en réalité ce
changement n'est pas pour la france un
bond en arrière de 45 ans un ré
alignement sur les thèses d'un seul des
protagonistes de la région qui nous
prive de toute crédibilité et de toute
influence auprès des autres
sous-entendu lionel jospin n'aurait pas
dû s'exprimer comme il l'a fait réplique
du premier ministre certains de ses
prédécesseurs ont aussi fait entendre
leur différence par exemple jacques
chirat je vous invite tous à vous
reporter aux débats aux interpellations
aux mises en cause publiques du
président de la république françois
mitterrand par le premier ministre en
1986 et 1988
à la sortie malgré la cohue c'est plutôt
l'apaisement il ya eu la polémique mais
elle est restée feutrée j'ai trouvé le
discours du premier ministre
rempli de l'incertitude et je ne suis
pas sorti convaincu plutôt que de jouer
sur les mots ou sur le mot l'opposition
était plutôt bien inspiré de d'assister
sur ce qui nous rassemble
par rapport à une politique élaborée en
commun entre le plus violent a répliqué
le premier ministre
au total sur les questions sensibles du
proche-orient de la politique française
et de la cohabitation les passions ne se
sont pas déchaîné l'assemblée
aujourd'hui à plutôt refléter une vraie
discussion politique aux pays bas où
jacques chirac achevé sa visite
officielle le chef de l'état a réaffirmé
que la politique de la france au proche
orient se voulait impartiale et
équilibrée mais il a refusé de commenter
l'intervention de lionel jospin plan
quand même à plusieurs reprises que rien
n'avait changé dans l'attitude de la
france à l'égard des différents pays du
proche orient
monsieur chien ce sujet j'ai dit je
crois tout ce qu'il fallait dire
au proche orient la politique de la
france est équilibrée et impartiale
c'est ainsi qu'elle contribue à la paix
et elle n'a pas changé mon ambition est
de faire en sorte qu'avec le
gouvernement la voix de la france en
europe et dans le monde soit forte
entendue et respectée
voilà gérard leclerc ont titré tout à
l'heure à un ton en dessous c'est vrai
qu'on attendait une polémique passé 48
heures et puis on s'était relativement
calme oui c'était un peu un exercice de
rattrapage sur le mode s'expliquer sans
se renier pour mieux tourner la page
un exercice aussi un peu d'équilibriste
le premier ministre reconnaît avoir
utilisé un mot contredire c'est
terrorisme est aussitôt pour s'affirmer
toujours sans indulgence pour ceux qui
utilisent la violence de même il reprend
les termes de l'elysée d'une politique
française d'équilibré et d'impartialité
mais tient à préciser les valeurs
auxquelles elle doit se révéler ce ce
pardon se référer et puis quand il
rappelle que la première cohabitation
entre françois mitterrand et jacques
chirac avaient été l'occasion de
sérieuses divergences diplômé
x est immédiatement pour ajouter que
jamais son gouvernement n'a critiqué et
ne critiquera de la politique étrangère
du chef de l'état alors on l'a compris
comme jacques chirac qui s'égarent dès
aujourd'hui de tout commentaire lionel
jospin a joué l'apaisement
c'est l'intérêt bien compris du pays et
également des deux responsables face à
leurs opinions publiques
alors on peut faire un bilan provisoire
de tous à écouter à matignon on admet
que les images des pierres à bir zeït et
l'avalanche de critiques dans la presse
vont sans doute causé quelques dégâts
dans les sondages
un mot une bourde a mis à mal la
tentative d'émancipation du premier
ministre sur la politique étrangère
l'essentiel est maintenant selon les
proches de se recentrer sur les dossiers
intérieurs la corse dès demain puis les
retraites la fiscalité avec l'espoir que
lionel jospin avec sincérité puis avec
l'aide de la croissance aura surmonté
cette épreuve comme il l'a fait dans le
passé avec les paillottes corses ou avec
michelin alors une bédouine l'a laissé
entendre cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale on a appris que les
négociations entre la syrie et israël
allait reprendre sans doute à partir du
20 mars prochain à washington
il y a eu plusieurs petites
manifestations contre lionel jospin et
le mot de terroristes qui l'a utilisé à
l'université de birzeit notamment en
cisjordanie 2000 étudiants défilé pour
demander la libération de ceux de leurs
camarades arrêtés après les incidents de
samedi on a brûlé une effigie de
virelles jospin défilé également à
bethléem ainsi qu'à beyrouth au liban et
des protestations peu importante à damas
tandis que la police palestinienne a
interdit toute manifestation fans dans
les territoires dont elle a le contrôle
dans l'aveyron à rodez devant la cour
d'assises qui doit se prononcer sur les
faits de viols et d'agressions sexuelles
reprocher à l'abbé jean lucien morel le
procureur a requis cet après midi douze
années de réclusion c'est moins que la
peine maximale 20 ans prévue pour de
tels crimes doivent certain étonnement
des parties civiles un rodez pour france
2 dominique verdeilhan et blaise grenier
un avocat général très en retrait durant
le procès y ont posé très peu de
questions l'avocat général qui balaye
tous ceux qui a pollué ce dossier
rumeurs ragots pour ne garder que les
faits et la personnalité de jean lucien
morel séducteur beau parleur je me
demande dit le magistrat si ce saint
homme est un tartuffe un profiteur un
abuseur ne cherchant que son plaisir
un homme de pouvoir qui s'en prend à des
victimes fragilisé isolés de leurs
familles en attente d'affection
l'avocat général requiert tout
ce matin les avocats des parties civiles
avaient salué le courage des victimes
dénoncer le silence des institutions et
souligné la force symbolique de ce
procès il faut dire à nos enfants que ce
qui a été fait est interdite
contrairement à ce que disent les
pédophiles les pédophiles disent nos
enfants mais ce que je te fait normale
ne t'inquiète pas ça fait partie de
l'évolution sexuelle relationnel et bien
là il faut que l'institution judiciaire
10 nombre dans la salle les habitants
toujours divisés du village aveyronnais
les anciens élèves du collège attendent
le verdict là des maurels lui offre un
visage de cire celui d'un homme
apparemment en paix avec lui-même
alors dominique verdeilhan on est passé
de l'idée d'un complot d'une cabale et
puis à ses 12 ans requis alors que peut
plaider la défense ce soir j'écoutais
depuis plus de deux heures les trois
avocats de jean lucien morel brandissent
face aux jurés le spectre de l'erreur
judiciaire alors c'est une défense
toujours très difficile à entendre pour
les parents des victimes à tel point
qu'il y à peu près une heure est bien la
mère d'un des trois mineurs a été pris
de malaise et a été évacué de la salle
d'audience je crois qu'il faut ce soir
se mettre à la place si je puis dire des
jurés parce que leur tâche est très
difficile où la nuit dit l'avocat
général a requis 12 ans de réclusion
criminelle
le maximum de la loi pour les viols pour
l'abus morel et de 20 ans mais la cour
d'assises de l'aveyron peut très bien
également écarter l'accusation de viol
pour ne retenir que l'agression sexuelle
c'est à dire les attouchements et la
peine maximale retombera à ce moment-là
à sept ans de prison
troisième solution offert pour les jurés
l'acquittement
le verdict devrait être connu aux
alentours de minuit merci dominique aux
états unis tous les trois jours
actuellement on exécute un condamné à
mort le prochain sur la liste funèbres
demain soir à huntsville au texas et
audel barnes il a 31 ans il est noir il
a été condamné pour le meurtre de son
ami en 1991 il a toujours clamé son
innocence et le moins que l'on puisse
dire à la connaissance du dossier c'est
que les doutes devraient lui profiter
mais tous les appels avec clémence
internationaux notamment ceux de jacques
chirac qui a téléphoné personnellement
au père de george bush ou de lionel
jospin ne semble pas pouvoir convainc
le gouverneur du texas de renoncer à son
habitude de refusé sa grâce
reportage etienne leenhardt et aaron
diam derrière les grilles du quartier
des condamnés à mort de la prison de
huntsville au del barnes est désormais
qu'à moins d'un miracle il ne lui reste
plus que quelques heures à vivre tous
les recours présenté par ses avocats ont
échoué et il y a quelques jours il a
tenu une dernière fois à clamer
publiquement son innocence je ne vais
pas vous dire que je suis un enfant de
coeur j'ai fait des bêtises mais là ils
vont me voler ma vie pour un crime que
je n'ai pas commis novembre 89 une
infirmière de 42 ans est retrouvée morte
chez elle
assassiné au del barnes la connaissait
il est très vite soupçonnée est condamné
c'est seulement il y a quelques mois
grâce à l'argent envoyé de france par
l'association lutte pour la justice qu
une contre enquête est menée dans ce
laboratoire les avocats de delbard 9
pour notamment analyser sa combinaison
sur laquelle des taches de sang le sang
de la victime ont été retrouvées notre
analyse a prouvé que l'une des tâches de
sang qui apparaît sur cette fameuse
combinaison est issu d'un échantillon de
l'autopsié de la victime ce que l'
expertise ne peut pas déterminer c'est
si le sang a été placé là
intentionnellement cet élément de doute
ne suffira pas à remettre en cause la
procédure le procureur de wichita falls
barry maka qui mène l'accusation depuis
le début de la sphère considère que son
dossier est suffisamment solide
une empreinte de l'accusé a été retrouvé
sur la lampe avec laquelle l'infirmière
a été assassiné on l'a dit odile barnes
connaissait la victime mais les
différentes cours de justice appelée à
statuer rejette tous les appels et balma
qui en est satisfait en vie cet homme
reste un danger pour notre société
je crois donc que dans son cas la peine
de mort est la bonne solution
je ne dis pas que c'est toujours le cas
mais dans le dossier audel barnes nous
avons suffisamment de preuves pour
demander son exécution malgré les appels
à la clémence lancés notamment par le
pape jean paul ii au d'albarn sera donc
exécuté demain tout le monde a peur de
mourir avait-il dit il ya quelques temps
à une chaîne locale
c'est une chose à laquelle il faut se
préparer
dans un autre état américain l'illinois
les autorités ont suspendu les
exécutions lorsque le gouverneur s'est
rendu compte qu'en 20 ans douch condamné
à mort avait finalement été innocenté
ici au texas les autorités n'ont que des
certitudes et au d'albarn sera
vraisemblablement demain le dixième
prisonniers à être exécuté depuis le
début de l'année 2000 en tchétchénie
l'armée russe poursuit plus que jamais
méthodiquement son nettoyage militaires
les forces aériennes ont mené plus de 40
missions au dessus de la tchétchénie et
l'infanterie citons près de la ville de
châteauroux ici le drapeau russe s'était
hissée sur cette localité stratégique
des gorges d'arguments 7 au sud de la
tchétchénie les blessés indépendantistes
ont été pour certains transporter jusqu
en ingouchie dans certains hôpitaux mais
les russes n'ont pas l'habitude de faire
de quartier de leur côté les combattants
tchétchènes
la firme avoir repris un autre village à
quelques kilomètres de ses gorges
d'argoun ce matin le journaliste russe
andrei babbitt ski de radio svoboda a
été rapatrié du daghestan jusqu'à moscou
mais il est assigné à résidence par les
autorités russes sous l'inculpation de
participation à bande armée
l'explication avec la correspondance de
gilles rabin efron brisset premiers pas
d'un homme libre mais manifestement
épuisé au pied de son immeuble aux
premières heures du matin avec sa petite
fille de trois ans rebecca mis au secret
depuis 43 jours babbitt ce qu'ils
découvrent en entrant que ces malheurs
sont devenus une affaire d'état il a été
sorti de prison et ram et du daghestan
en pleine nuit en secret par avion
spécial sur ordre du président russe
c'était plutôt étrange ils n'ont même
pas prévenu ma faim l'avion était vide
ma femme était là bas ce n'était pas
difficile de la prendre avec nous il
explique que ceux qui le détenait ont
essayé sans succès de le faire passer en
azerbaïdjan pour se débarrasser en
tchétchénie ils ont pris mes deux
passeports en utilisant la photo de l'un
d'eux
ils ont fabriqué un nouveau habite ce
qui a bien été détenus à tourner au
kosovo qu'il compare tout simplement
goulag stalinien et aux camps nazis et
où dit il il a été livré à des sadiques
comme les autres des plus il a promis de
tout raconter sur son arrestation sa
mise au secret son invraisemblable
échanges et surtout ce qu'il a pu voir
en tchétchénie ou est il fier règne un
arbitraire épouvantable ce que ma vie ce
qui va nous dire nous le savons des
onguents tchétchénie les troupes russes
se sont rendus coupables de meurtre de
pillage de corruption le torture de viol
et d'exactions sur des civils
mais il ne faut pas s'y tromper si
vladimir poutine a décidé de faire
libérer à témoin gênant c'est qu'il est
maintenant assuré d'être élu président
du mois prochain sans veut p premier
tour et que ce que révélera babinski
lille saura rien et puis je le rappelle
le photographe français indépendant
brice le tuyau est toujours retenu en
otage quelque part au sud à tchétchénie
et demain dans cette édition de 20h nous
recevrons la femme de brice fleutiaux au
kosovo a mis trop vite seules les
troupes françaises construites
actuellement un deuxième pont entre les
deux parties de la ville la partie serbe
et la partie habana c'est l'un des
signes voulue par les administrateurs
des nations unies contenter de
désenclaver un peu plus cette ville de
mitrovica d'autres sert de traverse des
zones albanaise chaque jour en utilisant
le train le train qui relie mitrovica a
pris stinat train placé sous forte
escorte de soldats italiens de la kfor
hans ponsinet gilles jacquier nos
envoyés spéciaux ont pris ce train
wenshan au nord de mitrovica
les serbes attendent leur train celui
qui permet de relier la zone servent de
l'asile au village serbe enclave est
plus aussi c'est le seul moyen sûr qu'on
est pour aller là-bas on ne peut pas y
aller en voiture ni à pied
arrive avec une raie minutes de retard
certains jours en période de tension il
n'est jamais venu
finalement les wagons entre en gare
estampillée ce cas fonds et le rsa c'est
le monde en deux manches et marc gasol
gabin les frais la grecque qui assure la
sécurité à bord à chaque voyageur au
détecteur de métaux
il y a du monde
départ toutes lumières éteintes ont
traversé le pont de mitrovica et des
quartiers albanais le train rempli de
serbes et vulnérables
on a déjà reçu des pierres lancées sur
le train et il est arrivé qu'on trouve
posée sur la voie des objets destinés à
le faire dérailler en principe le train
est accessible à tous et sur la ligne la
plupart des arrêts sont serbes
alors le train est devenu serbe c'est
désormais une sorte de corridor qui
permettent d'aller faire ses courses
visiter la famille est au bout du voyage
c'est le retour au village lui aussi
gardé par la kfor le lendemain au petit
matin toujours sous escorte le train
repart en sens inverse
les conduits par des soldats italiens
parce qu'on se bat pour ce train fiable
et albanais se disputent les postes de
cheminots 500 albanaise il d'être en
bossu et doivent peu à peu prendre les
commandes
pour l'heure ils voyagent dans un
compartiment à les cas ils souhaitent
voir plus d'albane et à bord on a
demandé à ce qu'ils remettent en service
l'égard des villages albanel et la kfor
trouve des prétextes pour ne pas le
faire en disant qu'il ya des travaux à
réaliser d'abord pour eux le terminus
c'est ici à quelques jours de leur prise
de fonction il n'ose toujours pas allé
jusqu'à la gare suivante parce qu'elle
est en zone totalement serre
le train lui continuera ses allers
retours à 102 zone albanaise en zone
serbe
mais que faire pour que les deux
communautés parviennent à voyager
ensemble en autriche irg haider a
démissionné de la présidence de son
parti ce retrait est accueillie avec une
extrême prudence en europe car il
pourrait bien s'agir d'une nouvelle
manoeuvre politique du chef d'extrême
droite autrichien qui ne cache pas qu'il
brigue le poste de chancelier d'autriche
actuellement occupé par le contraire
recherche où seule la communauté
internationale peu à peu s'organisent
pour venir en aide au mozambique des
centaines de milliers de personnes sont
victimes des ravages causés par les
inondations des intempéries ont repris
et le manque de moyens de secours se
fait sentir commentaires jérôme nie tout
ce qui sort de l'eau est devenue un
refuge où survivent depuis cinq jours
les rescapés des pires inondations
qu'ait connues le mozambique en 50 ans
rotations incessantes des hélicoptères
sud africains pour la plupart mais
sauvetage trop lent capacité trop
réduite des appareils pour des sinistrés
qui attendent depuis trop longtemps déjà
les équipes doivent faire des choix
déchirants explique une responsable du
programme alimentaire mondial qui mène
les opérations elles sont parfois
obligés de laisser sur place des gens
qu'elle ne reverront plus avec ceux qui
ont la chance d'embarquer les sauveteurs
emporte les risques de contamination par
le choléra
toute l'activité économique est
paralysée dans le sud du mozambique
le bilan provisoire est de 200 morts et
les organisations internationales se
sont lancés dans une course contre la
montre pour éviter la famine dans ces
régions où le cheptel est décimée au
nigeria les affrontements continuent
entre les communautés chrétienne et
musulmane au sud est du pays dans la
ville d'aba il y aurait eu 300 morts
et puis dans cette ville de kaduna on y
aurait également plusieurs dizaines de
morts dans ces violences les trois états
du nord du nigeria vont renoncer à la
charia la loi islamique qu'ils avaient
adoptée qui voulait mettre en
application ce qui provoqué les émeutes
de la part de la communauté chrétienne
l'assemblée nationale vient d'adopter
une proposition de loi instituant une
journée nationale à la mémoire des
victimes des crimes de wisches
une journée d'hommage aussi à ceux qui
ont aidé des victimes les persécutions
l'état français cette journée fixée au
16 juillet la date anniversaire de la
rafle du vel d'hiv
en france la baisse du chômage continue
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi a
diminué de 18 mille sept cent au mois de
janvier dernier par rapport à celui de
décembre 99 ce qui porte le total des
chômeurs à deux millions cinq cent 64900
selon les statistiques du ministère de
l'emploi alors exemples de créations
d'emplois c'est dans le nord près de
valenciennes où le constructeur
automobile japonais toyota cherche des
cadres et des ingénieurs pour son usine
de zinc
le recrutement a du retard car la
direction de toyota qui veut recruter au
total 2000 personnes d'ici 2003 a bien
du mal à trouver des ingénieurs
spécialisés reportage nathalie moisan et
patrick voix c'est l'un des plus gros
chantiers industriels de france tandis
que la construction de l'usiné s'achève
ici la ciotat recrute à tour de bras ce
qu'ils vont aussi travailler pour ces
futurs ouvriers techniciens de
maintenance et la troisième épreuve
montage et démontage de jantes deux
heures d'exercices bien peu ont déjà une
expérience dans l'automobile je suis
peintre en bâtiment parce que vous savez
dans ses traits à temps là l'opportunité
souvent bois sont tous que j'aime passer
du jambon je passe mon troisième test
dans le valenciennois où le taux de
chômage atteint presque 20%
l'arrivée de toyota est une bouffée
d'air frais dix mille dossiers de
candidatures reçus dans ce centre anpe
c'est moins qu'attendu pour ce type de
recrutement mais de nouvelles demandes
arrivent chaque jour
en fait c'est pour trouver les cadres
que les difficultés sont les plus
importantes car la toyota de réelle
exigence
c'est vrai que nous demandons à tous les
candidats à un poste d'encadrement de
faire le premier entretien en anglais et
c'est vrai aussi qu'en france peut
ingénieurs et cadres utilisent l'anglais
au quotidien et sont capables de faire
ce genre d'exercice oui et pour les
trouver deux cabinets de recrutement
sont sollicités ici on chasse les
ingénieurs sur le lieu de travail pour
les débaucher ces professionnels car
avec la reprise économique il y a moins
de candidats que de postes à pourvoir
le marché s'est retourné en l'espace de
18 mois en faveur des candidats
il faut le dire et puis on est sur le
bassin du valenciennois sa petite
difficulté déjà la terre du nord n'était
pas tout à fait la terre de prédilection
des cadres en france
et pour convaincre ceux qui hésitent
toyota fait tout pour gommer son origine
japonaise et se présente à valenciennes
comme une multinationale en revanche pas
de 1500 emplois seront supprimés en
france par la multinationale alstom
power avec des fermetures de sites à
belfort la courneuve et lys-lez-lannoy
c'est d'un département d'une heure
alstom power prévoit de supprimer 10
mille emplois dans le monde pour se
restructurer
les négociations se poursuivent entre
ministère et syndicats d'agents
hospitaliers le gouvernement aurait
proposé deux milliards 500 millions de
francs supplémentaires pour les hôpitaux
en 2000 dont près de la moitié pour des
renforts de personnel
mais les syndicats estiment que tout
cela ne fait pas le compte les
négociations continuent ce soir sur fond
de salon international de l'agriculture
qui se tient actuellement à paris
les productions biologiques publient
leurs chiffres il ya bien une forte
progression de production et de
consommation mais cela reste encore très
marginal le marché des produits bio
représentaient 0,5 pour cent du marché
agroalimentaire français en 1997
et pourtant on le dit on le répète le
besoin de sécurité sanitaire et de
produits entre guillemets propres est de
plus en plus exprimé par les
consommateurs et même les produits dits
biologiques n'échappe pas au contrôle le
tout est de savoir si ces contrôles sont
aussi nombreux aussi rigoureux que pour
les produits non bio
reportage françois veil françois vallée
avec françois privat et philippe ritaine
à petit dans cette ferme des deux sèvres
jean paul gobain travaillent en bio
depuis 88
il élève des poulets pintades qu'un
art il a environ dix mille volailles
soit cinq fois moins que dans un élevage
conventionnel elles sont nourries
exclusivement de céréales biologiques
pas de vitamines de synthèse pas
d'antibiotiques
ils sont de toute façon interdite en
agriculture biologique les animaux doit
on doit aller renforcer leur immunité et
on ne renforce pas les immunités en
combattant les maladies par des
antibiotiques
nous ne nous n'utilisons pratiquement
que des produits en rabbin a box de
myopathie toutes ces volailles sont
ensuite abattus et conditionnée à la
ferme
elles ont beau être bio quand la lame du
couteau entre en scène
il ya toujours un risque bactérien comme
dans toute entreprise de
l'agroalimentaire jean paul gauvin sait
faire régulièrement des analyses afin de
contrôler l'hygiène
toutes les précautions sont prises mais
je ne peux pas je lis a pas de je ne
vois pas de mesures spécifiques à la vio
dans le domaine de l'hygiène bio ou non
les locaux doivent être agréés les
producteurs utilisent les mêmes produits
nettoyants les mêmes désinfectant le
règlement est le même pour tout le monde
si en aval
de la production au niveau d'un atelier
de découpe il ya une contamination de
salmonelle bien que ce soit une volaille
biologique nouveau l'aï sous label ou
nouveau l'aï conventionnel il est bien
certain que la contamination pour avoir
lieu de la même façon dans les magasins
bio les récents problèmes de listeria
ont fait chuter les ventes en
charcuterie en revanche les clients sont
de plus en plus nombreux à acheter de la
viande bio ou pas pour les personnes à
risque les consignes restent les mêmes
évitez les produits au lait cru les
poissons fumés la charcuterie et les
viande saignante
petit à petit on trouvera de tout sur
internet carrefour jaune miroir de la
distribution en europe l américain sears
viennent de s'associer pour créer le
premier marché mondial
d'approvisionnement en ligne mais c'est
aussi l'automobile que l'on peut acheter
et vendre sur le net demain au salon de
genève qui vient de s'ouvrir
le patron de vivendi jean marie messier
jean martin folz le patron de peugeot
doivent annoncer un partenariat pour
rendre accessible internet dans la
voiture en attendant celle inverse le
marché de l'auto qui est sur internet
dans certaines concessions en pointe
reportage luc bizien et patrick voit
dans cette concession automobile peugeot
ce salarié a pour seule mission de
répondre aux questions des clients par
le biais d'internet
sur le site il suffit d' exprimer ses
désirs automobile et l'ordinateur fait
le reste
là vous cliquer sur recherche
automatiquement elle apparaît ici de
vérifier directement sur votre
ordinateur
c'est le plus besoin de craindre un
dimanche ou un samedi matin pour aller à
la concession voir votre véhicule
le véhicule est là et vous pourrez
visionner savoir tout depuis la création
de son site électronique cette
concession a gagné une vingtaine de
clients supplémentaires chaque mois pour
des véhicules d'occasion c'est aussi le
moyen d'agrandir la vitrine virtuelle
manque l'arrivée d'internet d'autres
concessions automobiles nous a amenés
premièrement déjà une vitrine mondiale
l'on n'avait pas avant bien sûr et 2
aimant une clientèle différente qui
connaît parfaitement les produits qui
est très très bien renseignés par le
biais d'internet
même le groupe galeries lafayette
s'intéressent à ce marché sa filiale
laser pour la fayette service vient
d'investir 20 millions de francs dans ce
site américain auto battle spécialiste
de la vente en ligne de véhicules neufs
au taux bas et elle reçoit 150 mille
demandes d'achat par mois et en
concrétise 50000 pour des voitures
neuves c'est donc environ le tiers du
marché automobile et des voitures neuves
française pour les particuliers c'est
assez considérable
un gâteau que chacun veut goûter aux
états unis 75 pour cent des
concessionnaires feuilles pour être
présent sur ce type de sites de son côté
renault qui vient d'investir un milliard
de francs pour lancer sa stratégie de
commerce électronique assure que les
clients pourront très bientôt créer leur
voiture à la carte
ils pourront cliquer la voiture choisir
la couleur la construire est
véritablement la commander au
constructeur si redéclencher sa
fabrication à partir du moment où le
paiement a été effectué auprès du
concessionnaire
en plus de sa voiture le client peut
déjà choisir son financement sa garantie
et son assurance l'automobile devient
presque un objet comme un autre vendus
dans le plus grand supermarché du monde
l'internet
et puis dans ce domaine le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel présidé par
hervé bourges a décidé de surseoir à sa
décision d'autoriser la publicité
télévisée pour les sites internet du
sport du rugby la série des défaillances
physiques des joueurs de l'équipe de
france de rugby n'est pas terminée à
l'issue de l'entraînement du quinze de
france à clairefontaine et avant son
match face à l'ecosse fabien pelous a
une contracture au dos olivier magne
qu'un certain et marc dal maso a quitté
plérin se plaignant de fin d'études du
cinéma avec un film réjouissant une
comédie parfois amers parfois très douce
sur ce que nous sommes sur nos grands
principes nos exclusion nos jugements
péremptoires cela s'appelle le goût des
autres c'est écrit réalisé par agnès
jaoui que l'on retrouve également dans
ce film dans sa première réalisation en
solo après avoir participé à l'écriture
de cuisine et dépendances nerfs de
famille ou encore on connaît la chanson
alors avant de retrouver son complice
jean pierre bacri l'un des acteurs celui
qui joue un chef d'entreprise
ok méprisé mais finalement heureux
d'être lui-même voici agnès jaoui
parlant de son travail de son film et de
jean pierre bacri présentation marie-jo
jouant avec vincent ferrer va dans des
bas c'est l'histoire d'un chef
d'entreprise un peu beauf qui tombe
amoureux d'une actrice prof d'anglais
c'est l'histoire de son garde du corps
qui fréquentent une serveuse amis du
chauffeur du chef d'entreprise
qu'est ce qu'un bon reconnaît d'où
exactement excusez moi mais je ressens
aucune importance ont jusqu aux chansons
c'est l'histoire des goûts des uns et
des couleurs des autres c'est l'histoire
d'agnès jaoui qui a décidé de mettre en
scène pour la première fois les
personnages qu'elle joue et qu'on
invente avec son complice jean pierre
bacri on parle déjà beaucoup d'elle
qu'en pense-t-elle et ben je sais pas du
tout avec la llagonne thoretton enfin ce
que j'aime par dessus tout je dirais
enfin et qui se retrouvent dans le fait
de jouer d'écrire ou mettre en scène
c'est raconter des histoires c'est trois
façons de raconter des histoires et
voilà j'aime bien ça tient sus le
divorce est ensemble depuis plus de dix
ans jean pierre bacri et agnès jaoui
cumule les succès elle ne dirige pour la
première fois comment elle réagit du
coup pas avoir d'enfant il ya des
nounours comme ça je laime beaucoup
beaucoup comme acteur aussi enfin
vraiment c'est un acteur que je crois
que j'apprécie énormément et je savais
ça j'avais une idée précise de 2,2
de lui dans ce rôle enfin donc voilà
après il faut juste faire gaffe à avoir
autant d'égards finalement avec lui
qu'avec un 15 connaître - cytos taylor
le goût des autres
un film comme une invitation à lutter
contre le trucage hills où est l'esprit
de chapelle
bonsoir jamais fait comment ça va ça va
bien ça vient je suis très contente de
cela parce que je disais c'est vraiment
un film réjouissant je crois que tous
ceux et celles qui l'ont vu enterré joue
effectivement le goût des autres c'est
vraiment le film que vous avez voulu
écrire sur les préjugés nous manière de
juger les gens si sans arrêt oui c'est
ça comment comment les milieux culturels
se jaugent se juche toit se méprisent
comment comment il faut dire certains
mots porter certains vêtements pour être
accepté par les certaines langues
un certain jargon et vous voyez bien
vous êtes exclu quand vous avez pas les
codes de claude camus qui qui
correspondent au milieu où vous les
ferez comme le film se déroule dans une
petite ville mais au fond c'est pour
être dans n'importe quelle ville oui ça
va pas important ont choisi une ville de
moyenne importance en province mais on
voulait pas que ça se passe à paris
parce qu'on voulait pas qu'on nous parle
par exane is on voulait pas si tu es
vraiment la province non plus enfin
c'est un petit peu et nous r ce chef
d'entreprise qui va faire une vraie
rupture dans sa vie sentimentale qui va
être amoureux attirés par d'abord un
texte bérénice puis une actrice
et puis les le milieu qui l'entourent ce
comédien va vous traiter comme un pauvre
type
bah oui ce que je vous dis c'est à dire
ils ne reconnaissent pas là un des leurs
c'est ce moustachu en réactionnaire on
ne va pas leur convenir ils sont arrêtés
à quelques apparences et voilà quoi ils
méprisent et méprisent comme je veux je
vous dis on se méprisent comme eux l'ont
fait en train de répéter exactement les
choses que vos débuts alors est ce que
moi j'ai filmé un disque quand vous
quand avec agnès jaoui vous avez
travaillé sur scénario sur le lecteur
est ce que vous êtes dit bon fond il
faut qu'on fabrique des archétypes de
notre de notre société
est ce que vous vous êtes c'est non oui
mais oui on se dit jeudi toujours ça que
l'on travaille parce que notre but nous
c'est l'identification des gens c'est à
dire que l'on puisse se reconnaître et
reconnaît qu'elle et ses proches
donc en général plutôt que de parler de
cas particuliers c'est-à-dire de gens
qui on sait pas quand que qui ont une
caractéristique très très bizarre très
insolite et ça ça n'intéresserait
personne sinon ceux qui ont la même
c'est à dire 12 personnes en france donc
on préfère effectivement choisir les
archétypes + dessert des comportements
courant quoi alors on avait souvent dit
que vous étiez un acteur tout à fait à
part n'avez vous jamais dit et moi ce
film là et puis j'ai lu dans le magazine
psychologies ce que diane et jouit de
vous son côté non comédiens surtout ce
nom besoin de séduire de plaire
d'ailleurs ce soir pas voulu vous faire
maquiller surtout être tout à fait
naturel vous avez effectivement tu vas
envie de plaire basse terre j'ai pas
envie de plaire disons que j'ai de
l'orgueil
donc j'ai de l'estimé pour moi même et
j'ai il me semble que je n'ai pas à user
des artifices dont il faut viser
habituellement et vous et vous verrez
que ça rejoint les préjugés
le mec il se rase pas par exemple ça
peut paraître inconvenant mais
finalement ils organisent heures ils se
rasent les toujours prêts ils sont très
très très bien rasé il a des très basses
mais bon il n'empêche donc je trouve
qu'il faut passer là dessus et que
effectivement j'aime pas une gêne pas
une certaine séduction j'aime pas j'aime
pas le sourire à tout prix je ne pas lui
être être jolie pour pour plaire à la
ménagère de moins de 50 ans je mange je
m'en fout quoi je je compte sur je
compte sur mes qualités propres sur sur
ma personnalité pour intéresser une
pente assez des gens si les intéresse
pas je ne vais pas les racoler je ne
parlais je ne vais pas les chercher
c'est compliqué quand même quand on fait
ce métier de la saisir de vie
trine de se mettre devant oui bah oui
mais il faut il faut savoir moi je
trouve qu'il faut savoir
il faut savoir ne pas avoir c'est cette
idée reçue la c'est-à-dire faut savoir
des tracteurs enfin moi je conseillerais
ça aux acteurs jeudi faut savoir être
soi-même quoi c'est pas c'est pas grave
et soi même c'est pas c'est pas si
dommageable que ça je trouve que les
gens qui les les gens à qui vous
plaisait qui nous font confiance et bas
ce sont ceux justement qui n'aime pas
qui n'aime pas les gens ordinairement
jolie et bien présenté comment vous
abordez ce métier de rentrer dans un
personnage vous essayez de me fondre
dans le personnage
ouf on vous dit non ça sera toujours
bacri oui moi je suis pas j'ai pas un
grand vin j'ai pas une passion énorme
pour la composition je trouve ça
toujours très bien quand on me dit que
de niro a pris 6 120 kilos pour jouer un
rôle et à moi je trouve ça vraiment un
très très très bien de sa part s'il
allait se faire chier comme ça c'est son
problème et c'est ça c'est sa façon de
concevoir l'acteur moi j'aime j'aime
jouer j'aime authenticité j'aime la
vérité
j'aime jamais devraient quoi j'ai
beaucoup de j'ai beaucoup de passion
pour la vérité personnellement donc la
composition allait jouer un gros qui
fait ceci ou un trait mais qui fait cela
ou mettre un postiche et jouer un peu
moins vieux professeur tous autant de
tâches dont j'en ai pas envie j'ai envie
de jouer des choses que je suis capable
de jouer effectivement j'ai cherché un
mois très proche c'est pour ça que vous
mais mounier djaoui vous avez tiré une
troupe d'amis il ya notamment beaucoup
de comédiens de théâtre qu'on voit pas
beaucoup au cinéma dans ce film que d
autres qui sont tout à fait remarquables
il ya une distribution en corse a essayé
lustres un petit peu le thème du film
sur les préjugés voyez c'est à dire les
réalisateurs de cinéma en général ils
vont chercher ils vont chercher des
acteurs ou les actrices qu'ils ont vu
dans le film d'avant celle un genre
petits camarades qui venait de faire un
film de cinéma où il allait engager
quelqu'un qu'ils avaient vu dans un film
au cinéma avant et donc c'est pour ça
que on se retrouve toujours avec les
mains de tête et je trouve ça dommage je
pense que quand vous voyez des gens
comme luc besson qui vous disent qu'ils
vont chercher des acteurs américains
parce qu'a passé d'acteur en france j'ai
envie de lui dire mais va au théâtre
parce que je vais retrouver des milliers
d'acteurs il ya des acteurs fabuleux
formidable
anne alvaro c'est une diva du théâtre
que que que les gens du cinéma ne
connaissent pas je vais pas vous l'avez
vu dans le film vous voyez bien que
c'est une actrice hors pair bon bah tout
le monde s'en fout c'est cégep à elle a
fait jouer deux ou trois rôles aussi des
masques étape tout à fait injuste donc
on va effectivement chercher les acteurs
de théâtre parce que ça
des acteurs c'est une réussite le goût
des autres c'est vraiment recommandé
merci beaucoup de nous faire cadeau
parce que c'est un journal s'appelle la
bougie du secteur et/ou soir à y redire
ce que les 29 février donc tous les
quatre ans alors vous pouvez vous
abonner pour le 21e siècle complet c'est
pas très cher et puis vous trouverez les
résultats des jeux publiés il ya quatre
ans voilà pense que ça devrait vous
intéresser la bougie du secteur merci
beaucoup nous arrivons à la fin de cette
édition je voudrais vous rappeler
l'actualité concernant le débat à
l'assemblée nationale monsieur lionel
jospin qui est intervenu répondant aux
questions notamment d'hervé de charette
et d'alain juppé sur son mot de
terroristes utilisaient à l'égard du
hezbollah
le ton était plutôt plus calme moins
polémique infiniment plus diplomatique
pour expliquer finalement qu'il n'y
avait qu'une seule politique de la
france c'est qu'elle n'avait pas changé
c'est aussi ce qu'a dit monsieur jacques
chirac allait à la fin de son voyage
officiel
voilà et puis 12 ans requis c'est la
réquisition prononcé cet après midi
contre l'abbé mouret l'accusé de violer
des questions sexuelles
actuellement la défense plaide le
verdict devrait être connu un rodez
devant mais la cour d'assises de
l'aveyron sans doute très tard ce soir à
23h20 vous retrouverez la vie à
l'endroit présenté par mireille dumas
sur le thème ces femmes qui séduisent à
une heure vous retrouvez florence du
propre dernier journal et puis demain
7h50
gérard morin recevra le nouveau
président de la commission des finances
de l'assemblée nationale henri
emmanuelli
13h40 questerre et rachid arhab ici même
à demain 20h bonsoir merci
qu'est ce
je